[Musique]
nous sommes en pleine campagne dans une
ferme dans la région de bourg-en-bresse
et cette ferme alain vila vous avez
habité depuis combien de temps 54 ans
c'est votre ferme
oui et c'est devenu un restaurant oui
pourquoi pas ce que j'avais toujours
rêvé d'un restaurant parce que j'aime la
cuisine qui voulait enseigner un peu ma
mère est un peu personnes vous avez
toujours aimé de falla qu'ils aient
depuis que l'âge de plus 18 ans et votre
mère vous laisser faire oui c'est quoi
pour vous la cuisine or pour moi la
cuisine c'est cette une patience et
c'est quelque chose de c'est pas vous
dire comme un tableau comme quelque
chose qui est autre que quelque chose de
beau voilà c'est votre vie oui est-ce
que vous inventez quelquefois des
recettes a toujours je n'ai pas de
recette précieux aliment pas deux pas du
tout où les inventer oui et puis à sem
ally si je réussis pas toujours la
première fois c'est sûr la deuxième
après mais la troisième vous et moi je
suis casanier a choisi dans ma cuisine
dans la cour dans le merger une femme de
la campagne au labour exit heureuse et
travaillant pour l ironie
j'aime beaucoup les bêtes je suis très
heureux quelles sont les qualités d'une
bonne cuisine
et alors beau et très propre et très
soigneuse et puis même à aimer
travailler parce que c'est du sens mais
qu'il c'est dur
est ce que vous pourriez nous donner
quelques recettes c'est à dire je ne
sais pas des tartes par exemple oui bien
sûr
et celle de tarbes bressane la tapa
loignon et là tu as ton fromage qui sont
de vieilles recettes en fuite
une tape au sucre à la crème vous allez
préparer votre pâte
oui aux femmes atteintes je prends de
l'appareil je fais une fontaine dans
cette montagne je mets une cuillère slq
beurre 500 g de beurre
combien de farine 1 kg de farine 150 de
beurre je malaxe pas parce qu'il est il
est ce bien ramolli un verre d'eau à
bordeaux
voilà
ce travail je peux mettre le doigt
et voilà on va travailler ça du bout des
doigts
c'est à dire très peu ma patte à reposer
une heure au frais maintenant je vais
l'éteindre chez chemise et mon moule de
papier d'aluminium pour ne pas qu'elle
school et pour l'empêcher de coller et
j'ai mis du papier et j'ai mis de
l'huile au fond maintenant flat pic pour
ne pas qu'elle bourse ou d'un four
partout maman n'a pas l'habitude de la
télévision elles se trouvent fatigué
aussi je veux prendre la relève
on commence par la tarte à l'oignon je
prends 2 oignons
je les coupe je les fais blondir dans
une poêle avec de l'huile
je les laisse refroidir et ensuite je
les temps sur ma carte
je prends la traîne j'en ai un peu plein
de gars qu'il y aurait une petite
cuillerée une demi cuillère et du
binaire du poivre et du sel
je remets du tout que je vais être sur
mes oignons elle la voix s'y prêtant
pour les plus tard je l'enlève dufour et
la voici prêtes à déguster cet argument
chaude
voici maintenant la tarte au fromage
faut pas oublier la pique et je prends
de trauma j'en prends la moitié pour cet
art
je me mets dans mon bol j'écrase un peu
sale jeu mais désire toujours un peu le
crâne
je pars au fouet pour que ça devienne
ambitieux si toutefois elle est trop
clair je mets un peu de farine
moi si je vais t'en jeu mais quelques de
maniement de partout au fait j'oubliais
de vous dire c'était du fromage frais ou
du fromage de chèvre ou un fromage près
voici je m'en fous
au bout de 30 minutes je l'enlève
la voici prête à manger et voici les
dernières tard toujours avec la même pas
la porte à la crème
je la recouvre dessus
j'éteins vous petite couche partout j'y
met du beurre
c'est normal manger l'enfant dix minutes
mais ça nous prendrait trop de temps
rousset supposons que je la sors du four
au bout de dix minutes et je la recouvre
de crem
je la remets dans le four 20 minutes
voici la tarte sucrée avec les tartes
salées qu'est ce que vous donnez comme
vin du mâcon ou du beaujolais
on peut on peut on peut boire du vin
compte du beaujolais et avec la tarte
sucrée ben pétillant petitjean paillis
ou à monbazillac ou un vin du bugey
pétillon mam et vous a donné ces trois
recettes de tartes bressane j'espère que
vous vous régalerez vous arriverez à les
faire
[Musique]